my best kiss ever was on my wedding day
with my husband yeah it's the best kiss
ever yes but my worst kiss ever was at
Aladdin I was dating Amy it was in
seventh grade my girlfriend and I was
just riveted by Aladdin hello he opened
best to everything and she tried to kiss
me and I was like Amy
Aladdin
what about you the best and worse I I
can't think of a a worse kiss because
I'm a good kisser you know and it's like
dancing you know people follow your lead
but you know George the man I'm married
to uh he's a very very he's got huge
lips and he's he's fabulous what was
your first kiss you know there was a
girl in the neighborhood she lived
across the street I was about uh nine
years old yeah and I remember it was in
our garage and the other kids in the the
neighborhood stood around us as we
kissed wow yeah